we got a free britney yeah brittany's
locked up
yeah man this is wild i've never seen a
conspiracy theory
turn out to be this accurate and this
like the whole everybody just got on
board this quickly
you know what i mean like epstein we all
kind of oh yeah he he didn't kill
himself but that's it
he kind of stopped there free britney is
a [ __ ] movement
he started with a bunch of kids on ig
being like hey blink your eyes twice if
you're a hostage
yeah and now it is a full-on [ __ ]
rallies it's if q was real
yeah free britney yeah so what is the
information what do we
actually have so basically she was in
court
i don't know exactly what the eventual
outcome from like the court proceedings
are it's basically just like hear her
side to i guess end the conservatorship
right and she gave like a 25 minute
testimony that apparently got leaked
which i don't really understand if it
was legitimately leaked or if it was
oh my god if it was legitimately leaked
or if it was accidentally
like or if it was actually put out to
the press like intentionally because she
mentions that it was a press thing in
her actual testimony
so basically she just goes on and on
about how her dad is
abusing her that she's trapped against
her will that she's touring and doesn't
want to
she's working seven days a week without
a break and like she has no say over
what she does
the big things that stuck out is that
she has an iud implanted
yeah it's birth control like they were
forcing her to stay on birth control i
want to have a kid
with my boyfriend yeah and they wouldn't
let her and so like there's all these
things she's like i'm paying people
but i work for them like i'm making all
this money but i don't get any of it i
don't have a passport i don't have a
credit card i can't drive in my
boyfriend's car
so it sounds like she's a legit like i
think her vegas residency made 138
million dollars and she was receiving a
stipend of two thousand dollars a week
yeah that's why you old two thousand
dollars
that bothers me much more than the iud
have we checked in on her other kids to
know if she should have another i don't
know
but if you're making 138 million you
getting one percent of whatever the [ __ ]
that is
no chance there's a 1.1 [ __ ] that yo
yeah
yeah i don't think the boyfriend's
complaining about the iuds probably
you don't think he wants that like a doc
baby or whatever that thing is what do
mexicans call it anchor baby anchor baby
oh he want you want to get brittany
pregnant bro yeah you want her free and
pregnant
actually yeah cause i think almost every
dude that was with her
in the beginning just wanted the kid and
then they dipped a little while after
yeah unless they did because she was
crazy but
the dancer guy the dancer dude fed is
the real victim in all this
he was living off her child support now
he can't even get that dog oh [ __ ]
wait why can't he get it i mean well
he's getting way less than he should if
she's no he wasn't living on child
support he was living off of uh
or something like that yeah but she's
making a hundred whatever thousand a
year now as opposed to
no she's still making 138 million she
just doesn't have control of her money
so he can get it from her
his folks of course if that's what he
deserves he's probably getting more than
[ __ ]
this is crazy okay
we need to check in with kate now get k
fed on the podcast that's what i want to
talk to
dove make that happen i mean that 100
percent sincerely we need to talk to k
fed uh yeah the interesting thing about
this britney situation is like
we were all completely convinced she was
crazy it's very easy to convince someone
or convince the public that someone's
crazy i don't know why we want to
believe it so much like you just need
one outburst as if we haven't had
an emotional moment right and all of our
horrible moments are not captured on
camera
right they're not captured on audio
whenever we have it but
every single bad moment that you have
publicly as a celebrity is captured
and you are then crazy i mean dave
chappelle was crazy they called that man
crazy yeah right
he went from crazy to genius very
quickly yeah the second he just started
talking again people were like oh no
he's a genius yeah i forgot i forgot oh
this guy's not crazy he's talking i'm
listening he's a little crazy crazy so i
believe it and now i
hear him talk and he's a genius so we're
so quick to believe that somebody is
crazy because
it doesn't take up any mental bandwidth
to dismiss a person he said it and it's
inside the actor's studio
so that's the worst thing to call a
person because it's dismissive yeah but
that's why we like it because
i don't have to think about it i don't
understand why we're so willing it's
convenient
to just oh britney's going through some
[ __ ] what's going on i could research
and figure it out
or [ __ ] is crazy yeah right right
what's easier for us
to live our lives shorty shaved her head
off like
that conservative started right after
that and hit the dad was
everyone couldn't wait that's who saved
her i want to get into the dad thing in
a second because it's interesting that
relationship because there's like one
component that makes it tricky right
there's one component that makes him a
leech instead of a savior
but but about the crazy thing i
understand that it
uh it's dismissive i don't understand
why it's so believable right i think
it's convenient so we believe it but i
don't i think what you're missing and
what i'm trying to communicate is i
don't understand why we're so willing to
believe it like
if i said that um if i said that al
is uh uh sick or his heart is failing or
maybe he has cancer
or he'll get hair loss not putting all
that [ __ ] on his free merch maybe he
wants mercury from someone you know
yeah but i guess i'm saying like why is
it why is that so easy for us to leave
why
why don't we reject it right here's
somebody that we've heard speak we have
so much
we have so much experience with this
person being brilliant right in dave's
uh situation and so little experience
with him being
crazy but the second it was said it was
like oh i guess he's crazy and then i'm
just gonna wipe away all that other i
think as long as there's behavior that
you can't understand
and there's no mode of explanation that
you can't actually hear the words that
they're saying
right the only other explanation from my
perspective is that you're crazy so it's
cognitive dissonance
right it's like the way that we feel
about somebody is different than the way
that we
uh then that person is acting and we
have to adjust those two things
and the adjustment is oh i guess they're
they're crazy when i was you guys said
i'm much smarter than me yes
gotcha okay okay okay yeah it's just
it's just so interesting that you can
like label somebody as that and then
immediately will leave it
yeah because then you're just saying
well my mind is free and clear to not
try to figure out
how why she's acting like this what
could be going on now like exactly like
mark said no oh she's crazy
done that's an explanation as long as
they're behaving in a way that you don't
understand
yeah yeah dave walks away from 60
million you're like oh he must be crazy
went to africa why would you go to
africa yeah walk away from 60 million
that's when he explains it you go oh
he's actually not crazy
yeah well this is the importance of
being able to you know have
like platforms yep right because you get
to control your narrative don't let
[ __ ] take your narrative and
run with it
because i mean i wonder i mean if dave
back in the day if he just came out and
said and britney same thing i wonder if
they're like yo i'm not crazy i don't
need this [ __ ] conservatorship i had
a wild night i had a mental breakdown
people might not ever relate to the
amount of stress that i've gone through
in my life and then some people might
and they'll be like listen that's your
worst day who knows i'm sure we've all
had fights with our
you know like friends and they've gone
crazy in the middle of that fight and
then afterwards like yo my bad i was
wild and i don't know why i
smashed a bottle or something like that
like this is done crazy 100
100 yeah so okay what's interesting
about the
father to me is if the father wasn't
making any money off of brittany
you would think that he was doing this
correct selflessly correct
but he he profits off of her correct so
it seems like she's a gerbil in the
hamster wheel yes it's like keep on
generating that revenue
you're in vegas keep on running on that
wheel i'm getting i think he gets
he gets a one point five percent of
gross of the tour the femme fake salat
more than her but what's interesting
about gross is
that's before costs yeah yeah yeah
like he's like i'm getting mine off the
top that's a wild
deal that's going i don't care how much
money it costs to keep brittany sane
yeah i get my [ __ ] first yeah then this
[ __ ] gets whatever's left
foul dude that's actually oh yeah right
ugh that's [ __ ] disgusting dude and
then
and then uh he also gets uh i think one
point five maybe it's 3.5 percent then
he gets 1.5
of something else i can i can look it up
but the fact that he's making money
off of this conservative conservatorship
essentially
right by keeping her working not
allowing her to be pregnant if she's not
pregnant she can still do shows if she's
pregnant can't do the shows but i guess
as easily
yeah right he seems like the biggest
scumbag in history yes
if i was him for a branding perspective
i go all i do is care about my daughter
i'm not making any money off my daughter
at all i'm just here to help her yes
this is the conservative ship because we
want to make sure that she's healthy and
okay
i would believe a little bit more her
money's in a trust i can't touch it boom
once we see that she has all her
faculties and she seems back to normal
we're good she doesn't need to do the
fact that you're still having her do
shows and then saying she's not
um like mentally coherent why are you
working her then
yeah can you imagine a person that's
like you have to check into a mental
institution but you're like yeah but
okay let's let's they're gonna go to
work nine to five and i'll take the
money
but then after that you're in the
hospital no you're there for two weeks
you don't leave
you don't get to do anything none of
that adds up is oh she's not in charge
of herself
but she can still do shows and tours and
every night
a [ __ ] stressful ass vegas residency
is she taking care of her kids i would
assume he's
in charge of taking care of the kids and
there must be a nanny or someone else
that's involved
okay because my my understanding was
that she takes care of her kids
if she's taking care of her kids she's
gonna take care of herself yeah i think
she takes care of her kids as much as
like
an upper east side woman takes care of
this right but then you should still
be in charge of your own money yeah i
mean
usually yeah but that is yeah
yeah that's fair so she's got to live in
nanny which is nothing wrong with plenty
of people have lived with nannies but
that living nanny is like court
appointed so basically it's like you
could watch after your kids
with someone who really knows how to
watch after kids yeah so you're being
watched while they're being watched
exactly i would be fine with that
if he wasn't making money off the top
yeah you can't make money off the top
there's something that's
that's disgusting yo mark talked about
the guy that said the most evil man in
history and i was like really he killed
this kid
this to me is worse than killing your
kids this is worse that you are
enslaving your child yeah yeah and you
won't let them if you want to kill
commit suicide no no no no no i got
money to make she is a slave for you
yeah she's late for a lot of you matter
yeah
how many people is brittany a slave for
probably she's the dairy cow
parents the [ __ ] sister who's also a
giant [ __ ] for not saying anything
where are you at [ __ ] oh jamie lynn's
beard yeah well you got pregnant too
yeah she got pregnant dumb earlier yeah
ruins zoey 101 or whatever the movie was
oh she got pregnant while she was on the
child show yeah
yeah which would have been a bomb story
line but disney didn't want to run with
it
yeah disney [ __ ] for that one bro i bet
i bet dad suggested it but we can still
make money
where's she at bro where's she at that's
the tricky thing with like being a
parent in showbiz is
you can't have a job like you have to
look after your kids
but if you're making money off of them
you're a piece of [ __ ] yeah so what the
[ __ ] do you do yeah
what what do you because you can't just
go hey i'm gonna let these kids run out
al you got something go go i mean like
there's a little silver line into this
because you know how we look at like a
dog's life and they're like oh
they live the best life she's kind of
living the dog's life it's like hey
everything's being taken care of yeah we
give you like you're being fed
people are watching we got it fixed she
can't have babies
we take her outside take her outside
yeah
spade britney take her outside to get
the exercise and [ __ ] like that and like
come home and everything's
like she kind of got it cushy if you
look at it yeah
and it's a little different than like
child actors who like grow up with
you know their parents have always
controlled it and then you discover that
the parents like
stole manipulated i mean they put laws
for this you know like
when you're a child actor no matter what
money goes into a trust
that you can only touch when you're 18
to prevent like parents from stealing
but the dad came in this was like
2008 when she was like admitted to the
hospital
k fed got sole custody the dad was there
to actually save the day
and that's when the conservative
conservator ship started
and then it evolved into this and it's
like we'll analyze it's like was this
greed you developed or like
she really couldn't go that way can i
give you one little
thing that happened that with with your
boy dove during that period yeah go yeah
give us
a tip hollywood because i want to this
is a compliment to brittany that a lot
of people don't understand mark get off
your laptop
in 2008 that's [ __ ] doing homework
during the crazy
peak crazy britney where she you know
shake the head
the whole thing like she was coming out
of all of this um
almost no she uh i was working on a show
called how i met your mother
it was shooting its third season i'm
like that [ __ ] guy thank you
so i was i was an assistant on that show
and
that show was about it was 50 50 whether
it was gonna get canceled or not because
you have to once you get to four or five
seasons that's when like
home run for the next five years because
they want to go into syndication they'll
make a [ __ ] ton of episodes
it was teetering it could have gone
either way we're in casting and we have
a role for this like receptionist
and uh on monday was going to be a
regular nerdy actress playing this part
britney's boyfriend who was an agent
read the role and said oh britney should
do this this is like
sunday before we were going to do a
table read monday at pete crazy brittany
and the producers and the creators like
okay let's have brittany on
brittany comes on everyone was like
eggshells is she gonna go
left right crazy or not she was the
sweetest person the father
was there and one [ __ ] scumbag one
bodyguard
just standing there in the wings she did
the part because of
her appearance on that show it drove up
ratings because people wanted to see if
you go crazy or not
and the ratings brought this whole new
fan base and because of brittany that
show lasts another
six years made people tens of millions
of dollars
and so many people don't understand that
had brittany not been on that episode
that that show could have easily just
been one of these other sitcoms washed
away
you two use pretty i use britney i want
to thank you my cousin
said thank you people involved but yeah
that was
props but it started off fair that's a
perfect example i'm not trying to call
you people scumbags but like that's a
perfect example it's like
is this [ __ ] a little crazy maybe with
the best thing for us to do
not employ her and hope that she gets
some help
no no i'm gonna employ this kooky [ __ ]
and maybe she'll cause some controversy
and then six years later we gotta show
syndication we're making tens of
millions of dollars
it this is what happens bro i understand
when people are saying hollywood breaks
people
i do understand that it's not that
hollywood
breaks you it's that if you are broken
they don't care as long as you you're
making them money
and they will ride you to the wheels
fall off there's a book by iceberg slim
called uh what is that [ __ ] called uh
pimp right it's just pimp it's called
pimp by iceberg
talk about famous pimp yeah and he talks
about when you're done with a
a [ __ ] for a lack of a better word
that's what he taught when you're done
with one of your prostitutes and you're
a pimp
you can't leave her you gotta break her
and it's really [ __ ] up but like it's
a part of the thing because
something about like she's gonna make it
hell for the rest of the girls or
something like that you can't just say
you no longer work for me
she's gonna cause promise or whatever
you gotta like break her
and i'm not saying that's what hollywood
does people i'm not saying they're gonna
break britney but they they'll go we're
gonna ride this [ __ ] so the
wheels fall off
and if the wheels fall off then we'll
find someone else to ride yeah but
that is how hollywood breaks i don't
think there's like a cast of
characters going who do we break next
there's just the same people up there
going
who else are we going to ride like who's
our trick right now that we gotta
yeah like what's the girl's name uh she
shaved her head too [ __ ] she might be on
the way
black chick comedian uh tiffany
tiffany haddish you know what i mean
like tiffany dave gave her every
opportunity we are riding this thing
right now
she starts shaving ahead everybody's
like nah that's all good she's shaving
her head
now i don't think tiffany's crazy i
think that she's got a strong
constitution
but they will keep on working that no
matter what she's dealing with
if she starts to show signs they don't
care they don't care yeah
and i honestly i'm wondering like
does the average person like i'm one
does the average person care
can the average person remove their
success
for someone else's mental health i don't
know bro i don't think so because we see
it in music all the time too
it's the same way in music like they'll
just ride an artist the artist could be
having a drug problem they could be
kanye all the gangster [ __ ] getting in
trouble in the news and all that [ __ ]
and it's like
hey the music still slashes money like
people going kanye even if the music
doesn't slap if you give us
amusement we will watch and we just need
uh tiki wiki always use the term
off-ramp for morality so like
the second i can say oh i got nothing to
do with this these guys are bad
i can keep watching and then my
conscious is clear and i can just watch
this whole thing happen and our off-ramp
is for kanye at least for me
i'm guilty this [ __ ] is now he's just
faking
right because i'd rather believe he's
faking it
then he's really crazy and i'm just
soaking this [ __ ] up and talking about
it every week on a pod
and listening to the music and like
letting this crazy person just exist for
my entertainment yeah
so for me it was like uh the kardashians
are exploiting him and just riding him
that's them that are [ __ ] up
i'm not [ __ ] up for watching their
exploitation they're [ __ ]
profiting off of it yeah profit in terms
of entertainment my entertainment life
is way more profitable
i'm amused constantly by this guy but
they're worse so i'm good
[ __ ] yeah all throughout time has been
happening [ __ ] van gogh
cut your air off keep painting them
paintings
don't cut them shits off good it makes
me wonder like because one of the things
she said in the statement where she was
like i did everything right
like i was told i'd get out of my
conservatorship if i was a good kid like
i did everything i stayed pretty blah
blah blah but that line of like i stayed
pretty weird because it like it almost
makes me wonder oh is that why she
shaved her head
because she was like maybe if i can
remove what they
see as my perceived value then i'll be
useless to them and then i can just live
my life
so that makes sense that happens to
women who've been uh sexually assaulted
yeah like melissa young ages
i think what they do you ever see a girl
like she like get crazy tattoos all over
herself or like piercings all these kind
of things
i think what they're trying to do is
like make themselves ugly
yeah undesirable they never have to go
through that again
exactly the fact that al is laughing
right now uncontrollable
uncontrollably unreal imagine how all
the [ __ ] tattooed
pierced up [ __ ] are feeling right now
so yeah imagine how they felt when they
were touched on by their dad
and now you're now you chuckling when
they were touching them about her dad
and that's why they want to cover their
whole body with a tattoo so he won't
recognize them anymore
desexualize themselves shave half their
[ __ ] head you don't know what these
girls are going through so maybe you're
not saying make yourselves ugly but like
create a visual distraction to pull away
them [ __ ] became ugly
let's just call it what it is we can't
call this that's what they were doing
too they put a dragon
they put a dragon on themselves bro yeah
they put a dragon on themselves to
distract from their natural beauty yeah
they put the holes in their ears so the
dab [ __ ] some a different
no this isn't even insulting to the
girls it's insulting to the guys
attracted to those girls
because they have the same intention
that he said i want to make myself
undesirable
not all tattoo girls but those and the
guys that into them you're in ugly
chicks bro those guys
are britney's dad yo taking advantage
of all that trump [ __ ] yeah you
ain't [ __ ] yeah
al piece of garbage you're a piece of
garbage for laughing at this
no but these little girls have gone
[Laughter]
i'm just saying that is a good ass point
bro there's something there
yeah there's something and there's
probably a similar level of trauma
in terms of like what britney's gone
through and then what like an abuse
victim goes through and
she's it's obviously not as like one
horrific incident but it's years of like
mild
abuse so how [ __ ] up with weido as
like a culture like
the second britney did try to make
herself ugly we're like oh this [ __ ]
crazy
why you make yourself take this [ __ ] is
freedom yeah
boy she was so pretty before and now she
made herself ugly she got to be
clinically insane she didn't deserve
her own faculty she should have no
controllers yeah
put out an album sing [ __ ]
what is this bald head of [ __ ] bro
sinead o'connor didn't she shave her
head
yeah and don't we think she's crazy too
yeah she's she's a cute little ball
[ __ ]
is she no i'm thinking about chad my bad
yeah i think they're the same no it's
white and one is black
oh chad is black johnny's fine oh get
out of here bruh
i don't know where the h comes from her
name to be honest they should say
with a little what yeah with a little
line okay i'll give an a but where's the
[ __ ]
yeah where's the [ __ ] from yo we just we
do things in our community chill
and she's like no just miss words yeah
yeah
yeah black people with the spelling bee
bro after spelling your names they
should be winning that [ __ ] every single
time
yeah come on bro you could you could cha
day s-a-d-e yes that means we would lose
everything no you would know
you know about all the hidden letters
the silent ones you have a huge
advantage
you got apostrophes in the middle of
your [ __ ] names and [ __ ] we don't
care about that corny [ __ ]
watch your [ __ ] mouth al they gotta
get your [ __ ]
mouth we're at the olympics like getting
yeah we olympic to spelling bee
[ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ] c-u-c-k [ __ ]